one further down on the faisal Farook
works as a customer services assistant
for Virgin Trains he joined the company
after deciding to turn his life around
while in prison just before my release
version came in to prison to do
interviews I was one of the lucky few to
get an interview after the my interview
I was released I was told the Virgin
would contact us two months after I was
released I was working for virgin and
since then of ever since been working
for I'm not left the company has been
proactively recruiting people with
convictions for five years and has
banned the criminal record declaration
form on job applications around one in
six people in Britain has a criminal
record of those who've been to prison
75% have no job lined up when they come
out new research suggests that asking
people to declare convictions upfront
may be putting them off applying while
offering employers a false sense of
security
Adriana pace runs a campaign group that
works to get ex-offenders back into
employment for many people I guess is a
question of despair because they know
that were they to tick that box that's
regardless of their skills and
experience they would be immediately
discounted from the role and that is
very very frustrating when you're
encountering that day after day after
day when all you want is the opportunity
to gain employment to then be able to
sustain that employment and to rebuild
your life in a statement the Ministry of
Justice said criminal record
arrangements need to strike the right
balance between rehabilitation and
public protection and the current
measures do just that all cautions and
most convictions become spent over a
specified length of time after which
offenders are not required to disclose
their convictions employers say they
need to manage the risk in recruitment
but some feel this is best done in
person they often people with a previous
conviction turn out to be very good
employees they're looking to actually
turn around lives and will may be giving
an extra bit to the employer obviously
it depends on the nature of the crime
that has been
committed I think that's a discussion
that the employer and the interviewee
should have on a face to face discussion
employment reduces the rate of
reoffending by 60% and with reoffending
costing the state 13 billion pounds a
year campaigners say it's time to start
looking beyond an applicant's past and a
Brady Sky News